[Música]
llegó el momento de repasar a toda la
prensa con rosa pérez más de un rosa
bienvenida buena mañana de jueves ya
estamos terminando esta semana de
información en mañanero en directo
américa tras la tendencia de los
atentados de parís rosa como dice como
lo señala mejor dicho la prensa francés
de las portadas de limón y le figaro
buenos días raúl exactamente hemos
señalado le monde y le figaro porque son
los dos medios que en sus portadas en
papel pues destacan esta sentencia de
este juicio histórico y precisamente
como ahora vamos a ver no falta el
calificativo histórico en ninguno de los
titulares bien veamos por un lado limón
dice 13 de noviembre un veredicto para
la historia perpetua irreductible para
sala abdeslam le figaro 13 de noviembre
un proceso para la historia de 9 tras 10
meses de debate los 20 acusados han sido
condenados a penas que van desde los 2
años de prisión hasta la perpetuidad
salad abdeslam ha sido condenado a
cadena perpetua irreductible bien porque
para la historia para resumir
básicamente lo que ella comentábamos
ayer no tanto por lo que fueron estos
atentados los mayores de la historia
reciente de francia con 130 personas
asesinadas como por otro lado por la
magnitud que ha tenido este juicio que
ha durado 10 meses el más largo de la
historia judicial francesa toda la
infraestructura que se ha tenido que
crear que construir para acoger a las
2.000 personas que han formado la parte
civil a las 500 que han asistido a estas
audiencias a los casi 400 abogados
etcétera no y básicamente queríamos
destacar también como un poco los los
abogados de la defensa han señalado y
han respondido a esta sentencia y es que
la han calificado de pena de muerte
lenta porque recordemos la condena para
salida de slam esta cadena perpetua
irreductible no se puede de hecho
revisar la condición de encarcelamiento
hasta después de 30 años y precisamente
su condena su pena ha sido pues polémica
básicamente porque se ha centrado en el
hecho de que él se defendió de no ha
matado a nadie finalmente diciendo que
tiro voluntariamente su chaleco
explosivo sin embargo lo que ha retenido
finalmente la el fallo judicial es que
no detonó este chaleco porque estaba
defectuoso a pesar de que expertos han
dicho que habría podido encontrar formas
de detonar los si hubiera querido bien
éste como otros puntos que quedaron sin
resolver a lo largo de estos meses como
porque el lugar y el momento de estos 70
precisamente los que vamos el demonio
rosa ahí lo tenemos porque él y el
editorial porque el editorial está
dedicado a esta sentencia no exactamente
y álava de hecho como a través de un
proceso judicial ordinario se ha podido
juzgar unos hechos extraordinarios dice
lo mont que estas sentencias denotan dos
formas dos teorías distintas de la
filosofía del derecho que por un lado
las condenas bajas para los acusados que
participaron de una forma digamos a más
mínima en todo el plan que quizás no
sabían de hecho la magnitud no de lo que
estaban participando pues refleja una
cierta proporcionalidad mientras que la
cadena perpetua hacia la abdesslam
refleja digamos un principio de rechazar
toda posibilidad de redención y
reintegración de este hombre a la
sociedad civil francesa y por otro lado
señala y estoy lo he encontrado bastante
interesante que estos juicios han sido
lo contrario al fiasco estadounidense
del post 11 de septiembre de 2001
marcado por el uso de prisiones secretas
métodos de interrogatorio muy parecidos
a la tortura en guantánamo y por juicios
estancados en tribunales militares pero
eso vamos a ver él me dio media parte
del padre de una joven asesinar el pata
clan que efecto y reflexiona sobre estas
penas atribuidas a los condenados si
media parte ha ido recogiendo a lo largo
de estos meses el testigo directo
personas víctimas o supervivientes
de estos atentados que han escrito de su
propia letra un poco cómo han ido
viviendo todo este juicio y han
terminado esta serie con lynch que dice
imposible no estar preocupado por la
suerte de los acusados él es el padre de
lola una chica que fue asesinada en el
bataclán lo estamos viendo aquí detrás y
él comenta un poco su evolución en
sentimental a lo largo de estos meses
dice antes del juicio ya por su carrera
estaba en contra de condiciones de
encarcelamiento como el aislamiento que
se había atribuido a sala de slam dice
era consciente de que era una forma de
tortura y ahora está pena de cadena
perpetua irreductible dice que significa
condenar a xala abdeslam a afirmar que
renunciamos de antemano a toda
posibilidad de remordimiento de enmienda
y de rendición dice antes del juicio
leyó sobre los cargos que pesaban sobre
cada uno de los acusados pero tenía
dificultades para retener sus nombres y
sus implicaciones pero sin embargo
después de codearse con ellos tras diez
meses dice tengo la impresión de
conocerlos más que a ciertos miembros de
mi familia
sé cómo se llaman cuántas veces se han
casado los nombres de sus hijos cuántos
fumaban cuánto bebían si conducían
demasiado rápido conozco su vida
sentimental dice sabía que eran seres
humanos pero ahora esa certeza teórica
se ha convertido en un conocimiento
empírico y dice que cuando acabe todo el
proceso que se agoten pues todos los
recursos de apelación va a pedir
reunirse con al menos uno de los
acusados lo haré por mí mismo porque
tengo cosas que decirles y quiero
escucharles fuera del proceso penal pero
también lo haré por ellos para ayudarlos
si quieren a reflexionar sobre lo que
han hecho y lo que pueden hacer en el
futuro en el estado actual de nuestro
derecho hay esperanza bueno rosa
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información esta revista de prensa de
web mañana viernes por supuesto con más
pasamos a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado el día